save that money or invest that money
that is the question
of the day and what you should do
let's talk money all we talk is money
all we talk is money
all we talk is money welcome to sales
talks money on valuetainment economics
i'm your host adam sosnick and i'm here
to help you build your wealth and save
that money or
for some of you invest that money so
that is the question
of the day save that money or invest
that money what you can see behind me
are three
major topics number one the money stats
in america
today that's number one number two the
tale of the tape
saving versus investing and number three
what you
should do so with that being said let's
jump right in
to what's going on in america today so
first and foremost let me just start
with my
back story so who am i to be talking
about saving or investing like what's my
story
what gives me the authority to tell you
about saving money or invest in that
money
so let me just paint a picture for you i
knew nothing about money absolutely
nothing about money
i was eager to make money i knew that
and i got a job as a cold caller
for a financial firm back before the
great recession in 2006.
cut my teeth i'm cold calling i'm cold
calling next thing you know i start to
make
some major money so fast forward 13
years later i'm the vp of sales at this
major financial firm
life's good life's good life's good i've
made money i've saved that money
i've invested that money but what did i
decide to do
for you like i said you know what at the
end of the day i felt very fortunate
that i ended up in this field
in this career that i understand the
money game and i wanted to give back
to you so what did i do i started this
show called sas talks money
and basically i traveled all over the
country asking financial advisors
celebrities athletes college students
homeless people even hey tell me what
you know about money
tell me what people need to know about
money and the answer was
save that money make sure you save that
money save that money
save that money save that money save
that money baby
save that money save the money now
listen one of the things i've learned is
they don't teach you
this in school so i've set on a mission
on a mission
to break down money into a language that
you
can understand yes you i am here for you
that's what this whole show is about
is to break down money in a language
that you can understand
so as i'm doing my thing and i'm running
around and i'm talking to people
i say you know what this money game that
i thought was super complicated
and very difficult to understand is
actually pretty simple
so what i did is i developed what i call
the size six principles of wealth the
psal six six principles of wealth
the six things that you need to know to
master your money now if you have not
seen that video we'll definitely attach
a link to that at the end of this video
so that'll be up there so with that
being said the third principle of wealth
is to save that money but the fourth
principle of wealth
is to invest that money so there's six
principles of wealth number three is the
save
number four is to invest so here we go
i've traveled all over the country i'm
breaking down money in a language you
can understand
i develop these six principles of wealth
i'm all about save that money i'm
telling you to invest your money
so i've built this entire brand telling
people to save that money
but i have a confession to make today
this is the first time anyone's even
hearing this
so even though i'm going around telling
people to save that money
here's what i had to tell you the truth
is
ninety percent of my wealth is actually
in investments ooh let me say that one
more time
i'm telling people everywhere i go save
that money save that money save that
money
but the truth is ninety percent of my
wealth
is actually in investments so what we're
going to do today is we're going to
break down saving and investing in what
you should be doing
but first we're going to get into the
numbers and let's start with income
so let's start with income in america
that's what this whole game is about
it's about making money so you can save
that money
to invest that money so what are people
making in america today well the median
household income in america today is
just over
63 000 let me say that again
the median household income in america
today
is just over 63 000 that's household
income
now if you want to talk about individual
for a full-time worker the median income
for a full-time worker is 48 000
so what does that mean what am i saying
that the average household in america
today
is bringing in somewhere between four
and five thousand dollars a month
i'm not saying that everybody's making
that much and i'm not saying that people
don't make more than that
or less than that obviously it varies on
your state
your city your job your education but
these
are the median numbers for income in
america with that being said let's talk
about net worth if you don't know about
net worth ladies and gentlemen
you're missing the whole point of the
game it's all about your net worth if
you're asking all right sales what's net
worth well i'll tell you i'll give you a
definition
the definition of net worth is your
assets
minus your liabilities all right your
minus your liabilities what you own
versus what you owe that's net worth
so right here we're going to pop it up
on screen you're going to see a graph
yourself
but i'm going to tell you right now the
net worth in america today
and it's all about age it's all by age
so if you're 20
don't compare yourself with a 40 year
old if you're 35
don't compare yourself with the 55 year
old it's all about your age
bracket so with that being said let me
break down the median
net worth in america today so if you're
35 or under
the median net worth is eleven thousand
dollars if you're 35 to 44 you're
looking at 60 000
median net worth 45 to 54 124
000 55 to 64
187 000 65 to 74
224 075 and older
you're looking at a median net worth of
000 now you might be saying those
numbers seem
kinda low well number one they are turns
out people in america aren't saving as
much as they should
but number two what we did is we did the
median net worth not the average
if we did the average we'd be including
all the multi-multi-billionaires
the bezos of the world the zuckerbergs
of the world the elon musk of the world
and next thing you know the numbers will
be inflated so the median number will
give us a much
clearer picture of what the average
person in america truly has in terms of
net worth
now let's get into personal savings in
america
so i gotta warn you these numbers are
not
pretty okay so buckle your seatbelt and
get ready for these numbers hopefully
you're gonna learn something from this
and say you know what i don't wanna be
like most americans
most people are most people be better
than most people
so the personal savings rate in america
today is 7.6
so what does that mean if you make 100
bucks that means you're putting seven
dollars
60 cents in your pocket you should
strive for at least
at least a 10 personal savings rate
the average household in america today
has about 16
000 in savings now if you think those
numbers are okay
it's about to get worse did you know
that 25
of americans have no savings whatsoever
25 percent
no savings whatsoever 40 percent do not
have
400 to cover an emergency meaning they
get a flat tire they get a car accident
something happens that they gotta run
it's an emergency they don't have 400
bucks they got to put it on a credit
card
they got to borrow money they got to
take out a loan not a pretty picture
55 percent of americans believe that
they will have to work
beyond age 65. now i plan on working
beyond age 65
but not because i have to because i want
to something to keep in mind
69 69 percent of americans
don't have a thousand dollars in savings
that is a crazy number and here's the
craziest number of all
that explains pretty much everything 90
of americans
buy things they can't afford that's a
pretty sad picture
it should go without saying don't spend
money that you don't have
okay moving on a last couple of stats
the median balance of a retirement
account
in america today is 60 000 and here's
the number when it comes to investing
only 55 percent of americans are
actually investing so flip a coin on
whether you're an investor
or not so that are all the numbers when
it comes to income
net worth and saving in america today so
with that being said
it's now time for the tale of the tape
saving versus investing let's break it
all down now
so let's start with the definition of
saving
saving is basically the key to wealth
saving is putting your cash aside in a
safe
and liquid account two key words there
and liquid saving equals safe
and liquid you gotta get that money
access to your cash
safe and liquid now what's the
definition of investing
well investing is building your wealth
over time
keyword there time with the help of
compound interest if you don't know
about compound interest
it is also known as the eighth wonder of
the world so investing is building your
wealth
over time with compound interest where
you buy
assets where you hope to generate a rate
of return so now that we have the
definition let's get right into it
risk and reward so what is the risk when
it comes to a saving well there's no
risk
there's barely any risk at all why
because your principal is safe
and you do not have to worry about your
principle decreasing the one
catch with saving is this is a lot of
times you don't know this
but you could lose purchasing power to
inflation inflation on average
is between two and three percent over a
year for the last hundred years
if you don't know about inflation that's
where you lose your purchasing power as
an example in 1950
a coke might have costed you a nickel in
1990 it might have cost you 50 cents
and now in 2020 it cost you a dollar but
it's the same coke
that my friends is a quick lesson on
inflation so now
what's the risk when it comes to
investing well it's obviously a
higher risk your principal can go up
yeah
but your principal can also go down now
this varies
by investment so when you talk about
investment risk you got low risk
you got medium risk and you got high
risk it all depends
on where you're investing so with risk
you have reward
with risk you have rewards so what's the
risk and reward with saving
well it's very low risk but very low
reward what does that actually mean
it means your returns are basically next
to nothing
you're putting your money in the bank
your typical brick and mortar bank
you're maybe getting
0.05 percent maybe okay
if you're putting it into maybe a online
savings account
maybe you're getting one to two percent
that's best
case scenario so on average maybe
you're making one percent on your money
maybe so you're not even keeping
up with inflation so it's very low risk
very low reward here's the one thing you
got to know when it comes to safety
you are federally insured by the fdic up
to 250 thousand dollars if you're like
look
i'm not trying to take any risks i'm not
trying to play around i just want my
money safe
you're insured up to 250 000 by the fdic
but low risk low reward now what's the
reward with investing
well the reward is higher returns your
money making money on money on money
that's the reward okay when we talk
about returns we're traditionally
talking about the stock market or even
the bond market
you're looking at returns of five six
eight ten percent maybe even more
if you pick the right stock so that's
where your risk and reward come into the
catch with that
is there's no fdic on your money if your
money goes down you're not insured on
anything
so risk versus reward saving versus
investing
moving right along let's talk about the
accounts and the products that you have
when it comes
to saving and investing so what type of
accounts are we talking about when you
come to saving
well just a bank account straight up we
all have bank accounts here
we know what that is that's where you
keep your money that's where your
account is
when it comes to investing you have a
brokerage account now what types of
accounts are you going to have in this
brokerage account when it comes to
investing
tell me if you've heard these terms
before you got 401ks
you got iras you got roth iras you got
hsas which is a health savings account
and then you have a 529 plan the list
goes on and on
but these are the different accounts
when it comes to investing
when you talk about products when you
talk about saving what do you have we
all have
checking account savings account maybe
you have a cd
or a money market account but the bottom
line is this is just straight cash
there's a straight cash homie like randy
moss once said so that is what goes down
in a bank account
checking savings it's just straight cash
when you're talking about
investment accounts right what type of
products are we talking about we're
talking stocks
we're talking bonds we're talking mutual
funds index funds
target date funds we're talking etfs and
maybe for
my people out there that want to get
super creative and you want to invest in
alternative
asset classes where you got gold you got
silver you got commodities like oil and
livestock
i know there's a lot of people that do
forex out there and i know my people
love their crypto
so those are the different accounts and
products you have with saving
and investing now let's talk time
horizon
aka when you would need this money now
when it comes to saving
this is short term i'm talking three
six to 12 months maybe on the long end
you're talking
two to three to five years at the very
long end this is saving now what are we
talking about when we're talking about
saving
we're talking about an emergency fund a
rainy day fund or just a good
old-fashioned cushion so you're not
freaking out if anything happens
that is what's saving now what are you
saving up for maybe you're saving up for
a trip
maybe you're saving up for gifts maybe
god forbid you have a car problem you
got to fix a car
you're saving for that you're saving to
go shopping what i would recommend
as an emergency fund for the common
person out there is
save up ten thousand dollars now you
might have just heard what i said and
said ten thousand dollars
that seems like a lot of money
especially when you look at the stats
over here
but then you might be saying ten
thousand dollars i've got 50 grand in
the bank
well congratulations to you but for the
average person
try your best to save ten thousand
dollars something will happen to your
mentality
when you have ten thousand dollars to
your name a lot of weight will come off
your chest it's a very
very beautiful thing to save up that
much money you'll have a beautiful
cushion
in your life i encourage you to try it
you'll thank me later now when it comes
to investing what's the time horizon for
investing well this is long
term this is long term baby now let's
talk about it at minimum
minimum if you're going to be investing
you're going to be in the market for
three
to five years minimum maybe if you're
looking for wealth accumulation you're
talking five
to ten years now if you're talking about
investing for your kids college you
might be investing for
15 20 years potentially and obviously
with retirement
you're talking 20 30 40 years down the
road this is
long term investing so the best way to
think about it when you're saving you're
talking days
weeks months maybe even years
that's saving when you're talking
investing you're talking years
and decades so to put it as blunt as
possible this is days
this is decades you're saving for the
days ahead you're investing
for the decades to come so that's saving
versus investing time frame now let's
talk liquidity everybody wants to be
liquid everybody wants liquidity
well what's liquidity with cash with
savings well it's high you can't get any
more liquid
than straight up cash you can easily
access your cash that's the whole point
of saving now when it comes to investing
it's not
as liquid it depends on what type of
account
and what type of product you have so
what i have here is 50 50.
what does that mean if you have stocks
if you have bonds if you have a mutual
fund
you could sell that it might take some
time to do the transaction but you'll
have liquidity
but if you're talking about a 401k or an
ira
that is money you will not be touching
for 30 40 50 years
so there's no liquidity with that and if
you're considering pulling money out of
your 401k over an ira just please
understand that should be your last
resort and i encourage you not to do
that so that
is liquidity so now obviously we're
talking about saving we're talking about
investing we're talking
mostly about bank accounts brokerage
accounts the stock market
some of you guys might be saying well
i'm all about real estate baby what do
you have to say about real estate sales
well let me tell you what i will tell
you about real estate
i will say that for saving when it comes
to real estate you got to save up
for your down payment maybe you need to
be saving up 20 30 40 50
100 grand for your down payment on your
house
that's saving that should be money in
savings now if you're talking about
investing
with real estate now you're talking
about a 15
to 30-year mortgage where you're paying
you're paying
you're paying down your mortgage with
the hopes of appreciation so we just
learned a lesson there
saving for a down payment for the three
to five years maybe it takes you that
long
for a down payment now we talk about
investing time and compound interest
15 to 30 years in hopes of appreciation
so that's the real estate segment when
it comes to saving versus investing
now let's talk about debt i know this is
never a fun discussion
nobody likes addressing debt but it
needs to be discussed
so now when it comes down to debt the
relationship with saving is
if you have a high amount of debt and
especially if you have a high
interest rate on debt i'm talking 8 10
12 15 20 maybe even more
25 50 percent in some cases on crazy
payday loans
you need to not even focus whatsoever on
investing
you need to save and pay down your debt
let me be clear on that
if you're investing and you already have
debt a very high interest
forget about investing start saving and
paying off the high interest rate debt
conversely let's talk about low interest
rate debt
if you have college loans or a mortgage
and your interest rates are two three
four five percent
this may be controversial but i
personally don't think that you should
delay
investing while you have low interest
rate debt like student loans
or a mortgage and wait 20 plus years to
start investing so that's the difference
between saving
with high interest rate debt and
investing with low interest rate debt so
that's the debt component
so last but not least let's talk about
skills skills pay the bills what's your
skill level
well what's your skill level when it
comes to saving well it's easy
anybody can do it yes you you can save
your mom could save
your dad could save your brother can
save your sister can save
your friend could save your girlfriend
could save your boyfriend could save
it's easy everyone can do it and
everyone should
save that money now when we talk about
investing this tends to be a little bit
harder
not everybody can just say all right i'm
going to invest however it is
easier these days with online brokerage
accounts
however it's not as easy but the number
one thing is if you're going to invest
you got to start somewhere you got to
sign up so that's the difference between
saving
and investing and the skill level so
that's the tail of the tape
saving versus investing so the big
question is what you
should do so what we have here is who
should save and who
should invest so let's get right into
who
should save you should save if you have
short-term goals i'm talking the next 6
months 18 months 24 months short-term
goals
you're going to need access to that cash
we're talking paying rent
we're talking paying bills credit cards
utilities you need
access to the cash if you don't have an
emergency fund
if you have not saved up at least ten
thousand dollars i encourage you to do
that
save that money if you're all about low
risk low reward you're not really caring
about the interest rate you just want to
stack cash all good
save that money and last but not least
if you have a unstable job
if you're not sure where your paycheck
is going to be coming from
next week next month next year i highly
encourage you to stack cash
and save that money so with that being
said let's move right along
to who should be investing you should be
investing
if you have long-term goals this is
money you're not going to be touching
for a long time hopefully you understand
that hopefully you understand
the risk and reward factor the returns
on your investment if you're looking for
high returns
then yes you should be investing
obviously it goes without saying
do not start investing unless you have
an emergency fund
built up and last but not least if your
job
is stable it's secure you're not going
anywhere you have job stability
then yes you can consider investing so
that's who should be saving
and who should be investing so now it's
time for my key
takeaways basically everything you've
learned today i'm gonna break it down
for you right now number one you gotta
understand there's levels to this money
game
you gotta crawl before you walk you
gotta walk before you run
you run before you sprint there's levels
to this game
so understand that number one you need
to have a game plan for your money you
got to understand where your income's
coming in
where your expenses are going out you
need to hopefully have a net worth
mentality
we discuss what net worth was not a
paycheck mentality
78 of americans are living paycheck to
paycheck hopefully that is not you
and you're understanding the benefits of
building your net worth
moving on this is what i call the big
three with money
debt saving and invest hopefully you're
paying off your debt
so you can start to save so you can
start to invest let me say that again
the big three of money
you're paying off your high interest
debt you're saving that money so you can
invest
those are the big three right there next
thing on the list here is having a
cushion
there's no better feeling than having a
cushion when something happens in your
life
whether it's a car broken down your girl
leaves you next thing you know you gotta
you get kicked out of your apartment who
knows what's happening the fact that you
have money
saved up you have a cushion there's no
better feeling than that
again i recommend a ten thousand dollar
cushion for most people
cushion is a great feeling moving right
along understand
that things change and you may need
to be flexible what do i mean you might
have that cushion
you might have paid off your debt you
might be investing now but things change
you might lose your job
the stock market might crash you might
say i'm not i'm not going to be
investing right now
i got to go back to saving understand
that it's not robotics you got to be
flexible
certain times you're saving certain
times you're investing certain times
you're cranking up money into the
savings account
certain times you're going all in on
investing things change year to year you
got to be flexible
moving right along let's talk about
goals we talk about the the average
savings rate in america today is 7.6
percent
here's my challenge to you here's my
challenge to you
try your best to save 10 of your income
and invest 10 of your income
so what does that mean i'm trying to
encourage you to live
on 80 of your income if you can save
10 of your income and spend another 10
of your income on investing sky is the
limit in terms of your wealth
so that's what i'm talking about with
goals living on eighty percent of your
income
saving ten percent investing ten percent
and last but not least you can't
invest unless you save that
money hopefully you appreciated this
episode about saving
versus investing if you have not seen my
episode on how
to win the money game check that out
right here and if you have not seen how
to invest
today check that episode right here and
if you have not subscribed to
valuetainment economics please subscribe
below
and smash that like button while you're
at it and as always
save that money all we talk is money
all we talk is